daniel craig reveals
he won't be leaving his kids any
inheritance okay so daniel craig who's
who he's a double or seven he's james
bond right good looking guy
rock star absolute stunt of a guy says
he will not be leaving his kids any
money to his children from his
inheritance the 53 year old james bond
star was asked about leaving his two
daughters money and said isn't there an
old adage that if you die a rich person
you failed daniel continued in his call
to candace magazine
i think andrew carnegie and american
industrials gave away what in today's
money would have been 11 billion dollars
which shows how rich he was because i'll
bet he kept some of it too he added but
i don't want to leave great sums to the
next generation i think inheritance is
quite distasteful my philosophy is get
rid of it or give it away before you go
thoughts i'll give you i had two
thoughts and two questions when i first
heard about this story number one how
much is daniel craig worth all right
he's done five bond movies he's gonna do
one more he's worth 160 million so we
are talking about a significant amount
of money here that could be passed on
here's my second question and i
legitimately came up with this and it's
this how much does he hate his kids
because he clearly does i mean yes
you have to dislike your children to not
want to give them part of what you've
earned and i and i will not waver from
that now so he was married in the 90s
and so he's got a child that's 29 now a
daughter i think her name is fiona okay
so he's got a daughter with rachel uh
weiss no he's got a a young child with
rachel weiss okay he's kids that's
pretty solid i mean that's well i'm
going to stay with this okay let's let's
okay so then he he also has a stepchild
that's 15. and my thought is does that
step child annoy you so much that you
don't want to pass on some money i don't
get it i think there has to be some
rationale by the way he's trying to
justify this quote isn't there an old
adage that if you die a rich person you
failed no there isn't i've never heard
that in my life and i think you just
made that up daniel craig i don't
believe that is an old adage so i think
you have to get to the root of this if
you dive deep and try to figure this out
on a psychological basis with daniel
craig i think he has a dislike for his
children or one of them and he doesn't
want to give him any money i will i will
see daniel craig's quotes and i will i
will match him and raise him a famous
british soccer player named george best
has the greatest quote about uh dying
with money of all time he's on his
deathbed and he had spent uh for people
that don't know he was he was a british
playboy and and you know he was known
for lavish parties and and being a
swinger and stuff like that and he's
sitting there on his deathbed and he
goes uh
i 90
of my money i spent on fast cars and
faster women and the other 10 i wasted
and you know what hey man it's your
money do what you want with it but i
will say this okay and this goes back to
uh when i was coaching and i was
coaching young kids and i i was always
fascinated by
how different the kids the wealthy kids
were than their parents especially the
hard-working parents like dudes that
were contractors and stuff like that and
masons who had really really made a life
for themselves and then their kids were
like pretty soft man and and i i one day
i i asked him i asked this one dude i'm
not gonna say his name but i was like
dude you are the toughest dude i've ever
met in my life like you've got rock
hands like i ask your kids to do 10
push-ups and they cry like what happened
here man he goes my wife dude he's like
when you he's like you'll see one day if
you have money you give your kids
everything you never had and they will
turn into everything you never were and
that's
that's kind of uh his his uh you know
his mason philosophy man look that's not
universal but i think there's something
to it like i think there's i don't i
don't think daniel craig is going to
follow through with it but i think
there's something to the salvo of making
his kids go hey you better work i this
i'm not i'm not going to leave you this
i'm not going to leave you this life
maybe he will maybe he won't but that
that to me is a message to his kids
going you guys better get to it yeah you
know i just pulled up right now uh an
article from cnbc billionaires who said
they're not leaving their kids their
fortunes okay so you got zuckerberg at
the top then you have bill gates who
said
uh it will mean they will have to find a
way
uh on their own and he says it it's not
a favor to kids to have them have huge
sums of wealth
uh it distorts anything they might do
creating their own path chuck feeney
same thing
warren buffett same thing enough money
so they will they would feel they could
do anything but not much that they could
do nothing
michael bloomberg same thing
he said if you want to do something for
your children and show how much you love
them the single best thing by far is to
support organization that will create a
better world for them and their children
so not giving them the money that's the
couple only there was somebody maybe in
the room who had accumulated vast sums
of money and had children that maybe
could have an opinion on this so you
know you know what i would say about
this here's what i would say here's what
i would say about this i don't know who
we are on recently kai maybe you'll
remember this with your memory where he
said tell me who's uh
uh carnegie's uh great great great
grandson right now that we all know
about
tell me who is it
tell me who is the current vanderbilt
billionaire that the money got uh given
to that we know interesting
tell me who is the current you know
rockefeller that's a great you know
interesting first so tell me tell me the
richest man's great great grandkids that
still have the money tell me you ever
met anybody named medici yeah so
interesting so i interviewed a guy i
don't know what his name was but i
interviewed a guy from seattle do you
remember his name the guy from seattle
who was dealing with
all the billionaires in seattle and his
job was family planning
and one of the families he dealt with
was uh this big fund templeton franklin
temple some fun he the the owner was
worth five billion dollars mark demos
mark demos right and his job was to
prevent these kids from committing
suicide becoming drug dealers killing
becoming drug addicts drinking alcohol
and pretty much killing themselves and
wasting their lives because these
billionaires went out there made all the
money gave their kids everything they
wanted made their lives easy and they
screwed their whole things up this right
here takes me back to a book i read
years ago by jim stovall called the
ultimate gift i don't know if you've
read it or not i probably bought a few
thousand copies and i always have my
guys read it jim stovall on the move the
whole story is about a guy named red
stevens he's from a very low-income
family simple guy comes he starts
working for this one guy in texas
apparently i think
and the guy who he's working for
dies and leaves him with his land well
the guy takes the land they strike oil
apparently there's a bunch of oil at
this place well he becomes a billionaire
rhett stevens after he becomes a
billionaire his best friend becomes his
lawyer
he sits his lawyer down and he tells us
lauren they record 13 videos is what he
records the one video he records is the
day when he dies okay and that video is
going to be watched by all his family
members a fascinating story so the day
comes when he dies he's worth two and a
half billion dollars
everybody shows up his wife shows up
with two of his young boyfriends okay
his kid shows up his nephew shows up his
daughter shows up everybody shows up and
he plays the video he says well
if you're watching this video it's
because i'm dead okay
now
there's a few things by the way do you
guys hear that background noise the
music i don't know what that is kai is
it you
is it the phone oh it's the phone
somebody keeps calling it i got it so he
says uh so he says uh
so if you're watching this video it's
because i'm dead great he says well let
me start off by saying
that my son i love you you're amazing
you're great
you're going to get the 620 million
dollars of money under management and
everything we do he starts celebrating
with his girlfriends he said well here's
a problem
you have no say in it
you're going to get a small interest
that's going to be given to you the
money manager i trust manages the whole
thing now you
pissed off gets up walks out
honey i love you you're going to get a
real estate portfolio worth 600 million
dollars and the young boyfriends all
this stuff
but you have no say the janitors have
more to say than you do you just get to
live there you don't make the decisions
and he goes around everybody and he
makes these types of decisions at the
end he says there's only one of you here
that i have the ultimate gift for and
it's my nephew
for you i have the ultimate gift i don't
have cars i don't have a house i don't
have investment portfolio i don't have a
company to give you i have no dollar to
give you but i have the ultimate gift
you could get the ultimate gift but it's
going to take you 12 months to receive
the ultimate gift if you want the
ultimate gift come back here on tuesday
to meet with my best friend my lawyer
and he's going to tell you what the
ultimate gift is everybody else you're
dismissed the nephew gets up cursing him
out i knew he was cheap he wasn't going
to do [ __ ] for me all this other stuff
and the uncle says he says you were the
only one
i didn't do everything for and i didn't
buy everything you're the only one i can
save everybody else i gave you way too
much and you don't appreciate any of it
nephew leafs comes back on tuesday and
they sit down and it goes through the
ultimate gift and the whole process
about learning about hard work learning
about giving back learning about
teamwork learning about all this other
stuff
there's a portion of this message that
makes sense okay
but i think you as a parent can create a
compensation plan for your kids and the
compensation plan can be based on bogies
you hit what are the bogies you hit well
trump said three things i i want from
you no drugs no alcohol no tattoos you
do that i'll back you up now you may
agree you may not agree that's history
right don jr did some of that stuff when
he was in college but still supporting
them right you may sit there and say
well here's what you have when you get
out of high school like last time my
kids were talking mario was sitting
right next to me i'm like hey uh what
are you going to do when you graduate
high school
dylan's like i don't know that i don't
know if i'm going to go to college why
not
because i'm going to go to college and
all of a sudden they started bringing a
boarding school because a private school
they're going to there's a boarding
school
i don't ever want to go to boarding
school why because i want to live with
that so how long do you want to live
with me forever dylan you want to live
me forever i want to live with you for
dylan you're not going to want to i
promise you're not going to want to
i want you to leave me for you you don't
want to live with me forever like a
house pack yeah he likes the house a lot
moral the story is they said so what are
we going to do i said well look that is
going to leave you a portion of money
that you can choose to use for a couple
different criterias you decide what you
want to do with this money but if you
screw it up you don't get anything else
that's all the money you got so you
better use it wisely i think these are
times that parents
don't create a set of criterias for
their kids everything comes becomes
about giving it to them if you do that
and you're not there i was watching one
of these roast videos yeah where alec
baldwin's daughter says oh you guys know
who i am here's who i am ireland i am
the yeah i am the daughter of such and
such man and i got to tell you you know
him from this movie you know him from
that movie you know from this but what i
know him from is he showed up about two
half of my birthdays over the last 30
years
exactly and he doesn't laugh yeah huh
and he doesn't laugh so so if you're the
guy that makes the money
and you're not there at those birthday
parties and you're doing movies six
months out you're in europe
it's a part of that that kind of screw
the whole thing this is an indictment on
these rich people all right it's so easy
for them at the end of the road saying
i'm not going to give you anything but
where were you raising those kids the
reason you haven't heard about them is
because they these parents ignored them
forever and just gave them everything i
100 blame them if their kids turn into
train wrecks and they end up giving them
all the money and daniel craig i stand
by my statement that you just don't like
your kids i i just
there has to be a component of that in
there how would you not want to take
care of your kids all right i don't get
it so what is worth i just hope he keeps
making movies man i just want to love
him i'm going to add one more thing
pierce brosnan was the best bond was he
i think he's better than that
he's pretty good i think so irish too
pretty good good looking material to
work with so so basically all right so
if i ever have wealth what i'm getting
out of this is that i
if i want my kids to have it they need
to be worthy of it so i'm gonna have to
create like some sort of
legend of uh the hidden temple temple of
doom they have to be able to like get
through certain different levels of
security of course and then once they
prove themselves worthy of the wealth
maybe tame a lion i don't know something
like that is that like but you're going
to tell your kids at a young age so they
know what they're striving for right you
know you know kind of like the whole
thing well you're worth 100 million
dollars you die you leave each kid 25
million dollars because you're in the
math it's not going to be me yeah your
boy robert kiyosaki man he uh he was
asked once about generational wealth and
and it was uh some social was like don't
you think generational wealth is it the
compound interest and it's it's one of
the uh this it's basically royalty and
he was like uh no it's it most wealth is
gone by the third generation there's
like a third generation the point yeah
it's all gone by the third generation so
the habits is what you want to pass down
i'm not worried about passing down the
money yeah i want to pass down the
habits to you i picked up my dad's habit
of working hard that's what i picked up
i picked up math for my mom i picked up
an analytics that's what was passed down
my my parents they had no money nothing
was passed down to me financially that's
what i picked up now here's the other
part say your parents are billionaires
can you pass it down this is the
question i have sorry can you pass it
down without that desperation your
father had desperation you had
desperation right so there's passed down
desperation can you can't pass down
desperation you cannot pass them so it's
gonna thrive in their dna and they
should be fostered you do have drive in
your dna but for every steph curry
there's you know no no i don't disagree
with you you cannot pass on desperation
there's got to be a part for them too
but if you
become look at this lady at nordstrom's
man like completely broke down parenting
to me in 30 seconds
i'm in nordstrom's dylan's on top of me
i'm in the room i'm changing i'm waiting
for the next room to be open it's packed
dylan's wrestling on top of me i'm you
know we're always wrestling together he
always wants to wrestle me right he's on
top of my head and i was like you know
he got me in the chokehold and this
lady's like wow you know i remember
those days i said what days my son is 40
right now but i remember when he was
five i said really i said give me three
tips on parenting i always ask that
question so give me three things i'm not
gonna give you three but i'll give you
one so what's that it says you know you
when you threat your kids
that if they do something you're gonna
take something away from them
i said yes always keep your commitment
what a freaking advice
did you get it yeah if you tell them
yeah you're not going to get ice cream
don't bluff them yeah because you will
lose credibility if you tell them
they're not going to get ice cream don't
give them the ice cream yeah right
that's the one of the biggest things
when you see with parenting his parents
are like but it's my daughter and i want
to do for but it's my son
it's very true it only took it only took
one time for me to get the belt and then
i knew my father would actually give me
the period their intake is very
complicated it ain't easy and for
parents out there that do their best
look perfection is not the standard
because you're going to screw up you
just want to be able to do your best so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]